so for the vast majority of the patient
population there is currently no
solution and that's exactly what we
bring we develop the device
that enables um to mimic the surgical
procedure the outcome only completely
incision free
and um it's gonna be disruptive we
believe in this field because being
incision-free it will allow to shift the
point of care from the hospital from the
operating room to the doctor's office so
we basically would go like for a dental
procedure in the doctor's office
and have the prolapse repair and this is
something that is not available today
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet edith
goldberg the ceo of escala medical over
20 years of medical device industry
experience in development marketing and
senior management positions she has
diverse background in all stages of
product development of medical devices
concept to commercialization she is a
trained dentist and she practiced
dentistry for a few years before joining
the industry and in a few months she'll
have three kids serving in the army at
the same time
edith goldberg welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm fine thank you
thank you for having me
thank you for allowing me to have you on
the show i'm excited to talk to you in
these next 20 minutes about
your life your journey your career
your impact with the scholar medical and
really interesting problems that you're
helping uh solve i think the fact that i
never heard of some of these problems
may be one of the pain points that that
we need to talk about as well but uh but
but nevertheless fascinating topics and
and so um indeed tell me a little bit
about yourself about your background
before we dive deep into a scholar
medical
right um well
i'm it's not a wonder to me that you
haven't heard about this condition
because you're a young man and this is a
condition affecting women of maybe older
age or at least 40 older so i'm glad
that i would think what it's like to
know about it absolutely because it
affects 50 of women all over the world
so i guess
yeah it's it's really highly prevalent
but to your question
i have kind of a diverse background i
actually studied at a technical high
school with
focus on mathematics physics electronics
which led me by the way to be uh an
electronic instructor in the army
uh but i was fascinated from medicine by
medicine from a young age so um
because i'm very technical person i
figured that and i like working with my
hands i figured that
probably dentistry would be more
appropriate
appropriate for me because um i didn't
want to have the lifestyle of young
doctors
so um i practiced dentistry for a while
um and i enjoyed the dentist as a
dentist i had my own clinic i worked for
pub in public clinics as well
and then i realized that it was way too
boring for me so um i did an mba and
moved to the industry
and interesting how long were your
dentists for
three or four years something like that
that was enough but you also have to
study a lot to be a dentist that's true
that's true but i don't regret it
because it really helped me in my in my
next career
so what was that hard and because you
pretty much practiced for as long and
even shorter than what most people study
for the industry
was there was there a part of you that
made it difficult to decide to switch
and to make the transition because of
sort of the opportunity cost saying oh
well i studied so much maybe i should go
on for longer
well you know in order to
um focus on a specific field in
dentistry like you were doing in
medicine then you need to study even
longer
and this is when i did that the decision
that actually it's probably the type of
regret i think dentistry is a beautiful
profession just not for me that's not
the kind of uh of lifestyle that i'm
that i want i'm much more interested in
business and i really got bored and i
understand that if i do
things even more specific you know it's
in a specific field then i would become
even more um
bored and i would not be able to pull it
uh for much longer so i took a hard
decision i have i had my family uh
backing me up on this which was
important um
and i think it was um for me it was
definitely the right decision
i don't regret it and the years that i
spent in dental school and all the
background only assisted me later on in
my career so
um can't say that i love credit
mba getting into the industry what is
what is their goal where where are you
headed at that point
right so so i started um as a project
manager for a surgical sealant platform
in actually a private medium-sized
company
that several years later became a public
company traded on nasdaq and eventually
in 2009 was was acquired by ethicon
um
you know starting for a relatively
medium-sized private company that then
underwent ipo it was traded in nasdaq
and then acquired by a huge company like
ethical and basically was a great school
for me so it gave me the perspective of
all the stages of a medical device
company or or actually it was a
biopharmaceutical
company
and
actually i got the experience in the
different stages which um later on when
i served as i moved to another startup
company
in the fields of
biosurgicals
and later on before joining a scala
actually
i was the vp of new ventures uh
responded responsible for the deal flow
at trendlines medical so this was
actually the first exposure to
innovation
um and where i fell in love actually
with innovation because in this position
i got to review like i think i i
screened like close to 1 000 uh projects
at different stages early stages most of
them some of them just sketch on the
paper
um and this eventually led to the start
of 11 companies one of them was a scala
so um
it's it's a really great companies yes
is the what is the connecting dots among
these companies so if you're looking at
your you know entrepreneurial executive
you know career
what is sort of the the connecting line
that brings together all the things that
you've done
um the entrepreneurs need to be crazy
enough to believe in their idea and be
willing to invest
the time and the resources and be
completely focused on what they do i
mean um i think that the most
evident point in connecting those
successful companies is the fact that
the team is great is when you decide if
you want to invest in a venture
um i think the most important factor is
the is the
is the people because um you know
technology starts from one point and
then after a couple of years it gets to
another point
uh but you need the management and you
need the people to be able to overcome
you know urges on the way or problems
that are always there
and if the appropriate team is not uh is
not there it will never happen
so when we looked at opportunity you
know there are several factors it
definitely if it's anything innovative
that uh
brings something new um
if the market size is large enough it's
uh
what are the successful odds of the
technology but definitely the most
important factor is the is the people
amazing
going back to scholar medical
walk me through
you know the how you get to this pain
point
how you strategically think through
you know what what you need to be doing
as an entrepreneur to solve it and then
take me through your thought process on
on how are you actually going to grow
this and scale this with a potential
market of you know 50 of women which is
crazy right so um let me start by
describing maybe what pelvic organ
prolapse is um that'll be helpful
as mentioned uh it's a condition that
affects one in three women all over the
world and even you know more over 50
percent of the women that that have kids
actually will develop
some time of their life
and
currently uh well the symptoms um range
between the milder cases it's just a
sense of a
bulge or a sense of kind of a dragging
feeling
associated with pain and in the more
severe condition it can be involved with
the urine and bowel incontinence
so it's a huge impact on the quality of
life and many many of those women
suffering from it at earlier stages are
actually embarrassed or um they are
still not aware of of the condition they
see it as a natural
phasing in the aging which is untrue it
can be treated
so many of those women actually either
compromise on their quality of life or
wait until their stage deteriorates uh
their condition deteriorates to a stage
requiring surgery
now what we have and the treatment
alternatives are limited on one side
they are either just supportive devices
that do not prepare the just the first
line of treatment they are highly
inconvenient and the compliance for the
use is really low
um and these are 90 percent of the women
of the patient population um and on the
other side there is surgery that is
offered only in the severe cases only
about for 10 of the women
but those are associated with
complications because it's surgery
so many women are actually reluctant to
undergo surgery um
so for the vast majority of the patient
population there is currently no
solution and that's exactly what we
bring we develop the device
that enables um to mimic the surgical
procedure the outcome only completely
incision free
and um it's going to be disruptive we
believe in this field because being
incision free it will allow to shift the
point of care from the hospital from the
operating room to the doctor's office so
we basically would go like for a dental
procedure in the doctor's office
and have the prolapse repair and this is
something that is not available today
wow
as you're thinking through how do you
explain the fact that you know others
haven't really dug into this pain point
before and is it because of you know the
main expertise barrier is it because
people just didn't think that there's
innovation to be done here people didn't
care enough how do you explain this um
well it's there are similar um
devices but all of them require
incisions and the fact that they so so
people doctors have thought about the
how to solve this and or how to uh
basically find a solution that can
avoid surgery or at least delay the
surgery so there are other alternatives
that are similar but
requiring incisions none of them can be
performed in the doctor's office
our founders which are two american
surgeons um highly experienced american
surgeons and urologists from from new
york a urogynecologist from from chicago
um they perform these type of procedures
daily so it was quite obvious to them
that we need to develop something that
will uh improve the lives of many many
women and we did
um
what what are you know some non-trivial
challenges
that
did you observe in the journey like this
that i as the young entrepreneur may not
even be aware of as i'm thinking about
escala medical and the different
you know the different challenges that
come with it
so um
it actually goes into two directions you
know you can develop a device and you
would think it's perfect because you've
tested it in so many preclinical models
in animals and even in cadavers and in
your dozen of bench
models and it works perfectly but you
can never know until you test it in the
actual setting that needs to perform
it's the human body
um
so
i mean recently we completed the
enrollment of uh 17 patient to our
clinical study
and it's amazing to see a technology
that you've worked so on so for so many
years uh that actually performs and
meets your expectations um
it worked really
beautifully it takes like five minutes
to complete a procedure compared to a
surgery
we didn't see any
any
things to report or major complications
or at all
at this point
so it's really this is very very
encouraging
and on the other side you know on the
business side there are challenges um
related to fundraising i mean in women's
health in femtech in general
there was actually a nice rise not
in the the past year in 2021 i think
that over 1 billion dollars were
invested in in femtech
but typically this is a field that did
not get much focus from investors
um specifically also conditions that are
related to the older weight
age i mean
giving women giving birth and younger
age um these get some some focus and
some attention but i think it's
improving so with time it's improving
take me
30 000 feet in the air
and we're looking at the different
companies that you're a part of and the
different problems that you're helping
solve
how are you
deciding how do you decide you know what
you're going to be working on what
requires your attention what is most
urgent for indeed to be working on right
now and what could be most successful so
so what does that thought process look
like for you
so um you know at some point um you are
looking for fields that that are
interesting to you i mean um i can
identify some fields that for me um are
more interesting than others in in
general in in the field of medical
device if i want to appoint some
companies out but
mainly i think what i would look at this
stage is really a technology um or an
innovation that would make an impact i
mean that would really be meaningful uh
both to the users who are the doctors
and the patients and i wish i could have
shown you the emails that i get from
email from women all over the world you
know they're they're looking for
solutions so they find our company on on
the internet and they just send me
emails where i can undergo the procedure
with the device
um so so this gives a very good uh
feeling that we are actually changing
something
um and and it's true for other you know
for my next step or or for other
companies that i review i mean if the
company really brings has an impact
um on different population it's really
important
wow
indeed go back before dentistry you know
middle school elementary school where
did you grow up in in israel
i grew up in eurea
in australia well what really you know
sparks your curiosity where's your
fascination lie as a kid you know as you
roam the world you know at 10 years old
um
yeah i think uh first of all i danced
for for many years when i realized that
i would probably not become a
professional then then
dancer then is was the time i decided to
go study medicine i think
uh no i'm just kidding but yeah i danced
for many years
um i liked soul actually if you would
ask me what was my favorite subject i
would say physics i still love it um i
think it's understanding how the world
works so uh it was really i'm kind of an
analytical person more so i really like
this part on
um at school but i did you know i was a
very active kid um i'm still doing
sports um
every every time i can i mean every free
minute i have so
the decision to go into
the medical world in general what was
the trigger for that for you
you were breaking out i'm sorry
the the decision to go into the medical
world
what was that you know what triggered
that decision for you where was it
obvious
for a long time that you're going to go
into medicine whether it's dentistry or
anything else what was sort of the
motivation there
um just a pure interest no but it wasn't
um you know it wasn't uh
convinced until the
i think a
couple of years just before
signing up for the university that i
mean law school was an alternative as
well
so i could find myself in a completely
different uh field but i think that
um
at least you know it's not easy getting
accepted to med school here in israel
right so um once i did i mean it was
quite clear that i would go to start
medicine but it wasn't only for that i
mean i was again as i mentioned i was
fascinated by medicine uh from a very
young age and
it was definitely a clear direction for
me then the only decision i had to make
which i'm i don't know if this could
have changed by the way my career is
whether to continue uh to become a
doctor or a dentist
and uh i made the decision to become a
dentist which eventually made me quit
than just agree um
and i become a doctor it may have been
different but i really don't know
i love it
every day that you wake up today where
is this where is the inspiration coming
from to continue working so hard
and
and and continue doing the amazing
things that you're doing but you know
besides just you know the impact on the
on the end users at the end that the
lives that you're helping improve
where do you gather inspiration in your
day-to-day
so um
first of all i believe in what i do
i believe will be successful i believe
will come will bring something important
to many women in the world
and i and i understand that not
everything comes easy i mean you know
hardly success stories are are easy to
achieve
and besides i i really think that if you
want to achieve a goal um it requires i
think
at least roughly 10 percent of talent
and 90 percent of hard work
um
so when there's uh
there's a will there's a way and uh
this is what you know and the little
successes on the way the successful
clinical study the fact that we hope to
get fda clearance very shortly
um good feedback that we get from from
users and and uh customers it's it's
encouraging
all those steps along the way i can't
say that you don't have breaking points
in in between you know that uh
what's going to be or you know
especially when when you need to get
into a next financing round it's not
easy it's challenging
but um i think that goal um and
the end of the road we want to be is
very clear so
i love it if i were to ask you for a few
words that we used to describe yourself
or
what other people may use to describe
you
what would those be
uh good one or bad ones
i'm just kidding um i think i'm target
oriented i think i can say that
i'm quite spontaneous as well i mean you
know i'm not i can decide to more that
another field interests me then i'll go
um
search it
and i'm
i'm a bit perfectionist i mean if i
don't get something right then it will
take me time to get it but i think
it will be difficult for me to give up
so
amazing
i really want to thank you both for this
conversation but for all the amazing
work that you're doing and the
inspiration that comes with it and
obviously the impact on on everybody
else so best of luck with the scholar
medical with all the other initiatives
and then for this time and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you thank you very
much michael
bye
you